el Tribunal Superior electoral de Brasil
ha decidido aplazar al martes 27 el
juicio en el que decide si Jair
bolsonaro el expresidente tiene que ser
declarado inelegible la razón una
reunión que bolsonaro mantuvo en julio
del año pasado con Embajadores
extranjeros en la que criticó el
funcionamiento de las urnas electrónicas
sin aportar pruebas y sembró dudas sobre
el funcionamiento de todo el sistema
electoral pocos meses antes de las
elecciones presidenciales la fiscalía
general de la justicia electoral ha
hablado de abuso de poder y de una
maniobra electoral pensada precisamente
para influenciar el voto de los
electores la defensa de bolsonaro alega
que si es verdad que hubo una subida de
tono en realidad todo eso se produjo
fuera del periodo electoral y por lo
tanto no sería delito El caso es que
bolsonaro hoy ha viajado a Porto alegre
para participar en un acto electoral de
su partido
de Cara a las elecciones municipales del
año que viene acarició la idea de ir a
la sede del tribunal superior electoral
según ha informado la prensa local pero
finalmente desistió de esa idea eso sí
ha dicho que quiere quedarse activo en
la política aunque sea condenado y todos
los principales analistas del país creen
que la decisión ya está tomada habría
una mayoría de seis a uno para dejar
bolsonar o fuera de la vida política
durante ocho años solo podría volver en
2030 ya con 75 años hay que ver si el
juez lunes martes pide una vista
preliminar que podría suspender el
juicio durante 60 días recordamos que
este juez es evangélico y fue nombrado
por bolsonaro para la Corte Suprema es
considerado un juez fiel al expresidente